you'll have somebody like the governor  of  nevada come out with this massive plan  out of nowhere to take millions of  ballots and send them all over the place  you'll never know who won that state  it'll get messed up just like new york  and just like paterson new jersey and  just like many other places  in west virginia they indicted a a  postman  for doing something very bad you know  that  and but there are many cases all over  the country if you look  you'll be able to find there's a list of  them all over the country  and that has to do with universal  mail-in again  absentee is great it works like in  florida they'll do absentee it really  works  but universal mail-in ballots is going  to  be a great embarrassment to our country  well i have the right to do it we  haven't gotten there yet but we'll see  what happens we will be  suing in nevada and that's already been  taken care of we'll probably file  something tomorrow